last one because I I have to go to
volleyball
soon we're going to talk about or I'm
going to show Charlie Kirk sing because
I just need to talk about do you think
that people who procure abortion okay I
just need to talk about these
simps I can't take it any longer I
can't women specifically a woman who
procures an abortion should go to jail
for getting one absolutely yeah they're
the moral equivalent of aitz really yes
um I millions of women
basically the same as like Nazi the
women are victims they're lied to 90% of
women do not see an ultrasound before
they have an abortion they have no idea
what's happening to them they're the
victims here Google
it Charlie Charlie I'm sorry if I am
going to get a procedure
done Google it you can't Google what
happens in an
abortion if I if I women will Google the
plastic surgeon they get their bbl's
Botox and whatever else from they can't
Google what an abortion
is and so it's not their fault because
the internet doesn't this is
simping simp simp simp simp simp and
it's all because they don't want to hold
women accountable because they have
these tradcon female bases and if they
go in too hard on women it makes them
look bad and that's all they want they
want followers they want all this stuff
instead of just being
honest why would a woman not go to jail
if I if I hired a Hitman and maybe I
didn't know how okay let's just say I
hired a Hitman I hired a Hitman to
kill somebody all right let's just say
and that
guy pulled the guy's limbs off off one
by one and then and then stabbed him and
I said but I thought you were just going
to shoot
him would you have said oh well you know
what Pearl you didn't know you shouldn't
go to
jail dear God make it stop make the sing
stop I can't watch it any longer it is
the abortionists that are doing this but
let me ask you and I mean this have you
guys ever seen an abortion on a video if
women are the victims here why should
they be jailed well I don't believe they
should be jailed I think the the
abortionist the abortionist believe AB
is murder but a murderer shouldn't go to
jail I didn't say that the doctors the
abor I mean did he just get schooled by
a
304 he just
lost okay simpery simpery has just made
one of the greatest debaters
lose oh my gosh this is hilarious the
people that call themselves doctors the
people that put women under general
anesthesia and go into but the but they
take
it do they ask they are doctors they're
medical are you going to just discount
the accountability of my current
perspective is because the women are not
given what is called informed consent
okay wait I just want to show I just
want to show Charlie something okay I
just I just want to show him just in
case he didn't know okay so if
I was going to get I'm not so please
don't clip it and make it look weird
okay if I
said how to
get an abortion or video watch this
watch this watch this video of a
abortion oh oh my God is that
Google is
that but you're right yeah yeah just put
it on the men yeah it's just the men's
fault as
usual you know else is crazy they're
talking about the men that are sleeping
around but they don't talk about the
women do you know I swear if we had to
go to monogamy straight monogamy women
would be the ones that would break it
first they would be begging to be a side
chick and if you take side chick if you
don't let side chicks be side chicks
they will be devastated okay that's the
first women women will come back and say
please please let me be a side chick I
want to sleep with Drake I want to sleep
with future please please let me back in
if if they went to the men and said you
evil men one woman for life do you know
who would break it first freaking women
women women women women women women go
go to any concert do you know who's
throwing themel it's not the the evil
men the evil men at Drake's concert just
Drake's going out and saying women
please sleep with me no it's the women
it's the women saying please please take
us take us please and it's like the
tradcons will say oh but she was just
young she didn't know what she was doing
and then you'll look at like a
18-year-old chick or 19-year-old chick
and she's like I want to do that one
please please take me please oh
please I just can't I can't deal with
the simpery I just want the simpery to
die that's what I want I want the
simpery to go away okay when are the
victims here why should they be jailed
well I don't believe they should be
jailed I think the the
abortionist believe that abortion is
murder but a murderer shouldn't go to
jail I didn't say that the doctors the
abortionists the people that call
themselves doctors the people that put
women under general anesthesia and go in
into women do they ask they are doctors
they're medical are you going to just
discount the accountability of my Cur
perspective is because the women are not
given what is called informed consent
that the women should not be penalized
would you say abortion is murder what is
informed
consent they know they're killing a kid
okay like but this is why guys women
have always killed their children this
idea that women are more
nurturing I don't believe it for a
second that's just women running their
marketing schemes to make us seem more
special and important and awesome than
we are if we're more n nurturing why do
we kill kids after they're born we're
the most likely ones to kill the kids
after they're born in the first year of
Life men never do it we're also the most
likely ones to kill the
elderly who is the more violent sex the
one that goes against the freaking
innocent the innocent
okay
now then they'll just say the evil men
the evil men the evil evil evil evil men
and I just can't I can't take this
simping I can't take you tradcons
talking for a week about how 10% of men
are screwing women women know damn well
what they're getting into they're not
these innocent creatures that are just
Bamboozled and have no idea what's going
on stop it stop it stop it stop it stop
it I can't I can't deal
I can't deal and um one of the tradcons
decided that he was going to investigate
my family because we
have a different
opinion on
cheating this is the level of of
Christianity these guys push okay um you
know I don't bring in his family to it
quite quite rude quite I'm just saying
quite
quite quite
rude and these guys will do this under
the guys of being
these Christianity so this is my thing
this is my plea to the Christians all
right fix your churches figure out get
rid of the you have only figured out how
to get simp men in the church you have
not figured out how to get the actual
actual masculine men that women want in
the
church and until you figure out how to
get them back in the church you will
keep
losing you will keep losing the culture
will still go one way the church is
still going to be feminized because all
you have is simps in the church you're
going to keep marrying these Born Again
hoes and the men with the option to not
do that are just going to say I'm gonna
bow out I'm gonna just not be religious
and the number one reason that they're
going to give on their way out is
hypocrisy so
I don't
know I'm not a preacher do you think
that I'm not a preacher I just give my
opinions you can take it or leave it you
know let me know let me know what you
guys think can the comments uh like the
video on your way out and please let me
I think there was a couple cash apps I'm
gonna get to
them all right Phillip oh I read his
Charles Silva says I really appreciate
your honesty and all the problems you
talk about within the church which are
real come from
from incorrect dot dot dot I guess I
guess I'll find out one day what the dot
dot dot
is I don't know
okay one second
guys thank you fasil Loi and
pearl um from Matthew
malalo yeah thank you guys for the for
the cash app super chats if you're
rewatching this later feel free to send
send some money as we are demonetized
like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel